he's Matt Walsh actor comedian and
founding member of the uprights citizen
brigade troop you can also catch him in
veep on HBO s that's sundays at ten
thirty eastern i believe you know he's
in ghostbusters yeah and the do-over
available on netflix beginning next
friday may 27th the adam sandler movie
you were in old school though weren't
were you got one scene or two to sings
an old school I had a nice arc I was
Walsh in old school I played a character
named Walsh was a stretch but did you
take do you purposely take your real
last name well I'm buddies with Scott
Armstrong who wrote it with Todd
Phillips so I think Scott and Todd had
me in mind for that role I guess yeah
yeah but I did go in for an audition for
a character named Walsh like what was
the scene that you were I get slapped by
Luke in the office I'm in the end when
Farrell starts the new fraternity I go
through a couple like a lot of office
scenes when Goldberg the boss yeah
played by forget so I'm kind of mostly
in the office world but there's a couple
fraternity things I did I haven't seen
in a while how much fun is is the set
really fun really fun I mean with like
guys like will ferrell running around
it's always a good time and todd
phillips is a pretty improv friendly
director so he lets you try a little bit
and it was really fun but when you have
guys like that and who were great
comedic actors hmm does the director
trust you to do let's do improv here
like what do you feel or think let's
just do it you can't really what they do
is because they've worked so hard on the
script you shoot what they have like
let's get what we wrote and then they
start playing with things that aren't
working or logo do you have any ideas
but you try to execute what they've
labored over over the last year or two
to make sure you get that right and then
they'll give you opportunity to try
different things how hard is it to not
laugh uh it depends that I've gotten
better at not laughing I used to be
terrible at laughing and I've gotten
better at it but it can be hard
especially if it's a confined space like
on veep whenever we do limo scenes
you're basically sitting right on top of
each other it's like the giggles in
church just
I just I just always laugh I can't not
left also because half the team is off
camera there's a camera guy there and so
they're kind of messing with you as well
to sort of get you to laugh the process
of veep take us through like a legit
what's a normal week like uh well we'll
do a table read of every script and then
after the table read will put the
scripts down and we'll work on things
that the head writer or the director
want to see or make better and then the
writers will be in the room and they'll
go away and do another draft and then
we'll do that for every script or every
you know two or three times until it's
right and then we're on set it's ninety
percent written for sure you just hit
the words and get out is it's pretty
rapid fire they don't log yeah and then
you get to tweak it or you can pitch
jokes all day or you can try different
bits but when we're filming it's pretty
much as written and Julia Louie Dreyfus
is tough terrible anyone be yes yeah
yeah diva kind of like JLo you can't
look her in the eyes you know that kind
of thing what's the most awkward moment
you've ever had with her awkward moments
oh my god uh I wish I had a good answer
awkward moment I don't know I don't know
that I've had like a awkward moment with
Julia you haven't stared at her and
thought about making out with her
anything like that like or is that just
me she like uh when I didn't have her
breakfast for at the trailer like if
you're a new cast member you have to
make it like rookies you have to make
breakfast or for the first year and I
didn't have her breakfast one year and
she had a bit of a tirade Wow and I got
back I got backhanded I like that she
has a pimp an actually if she raises if
she raises the pimp and you better get
get it right or get out of the way nah I
understand that it's mostly a threat she
won't use it but she definitely has a
champion and it changes sometimes is
this one and you don't realize how
brilliant when she was in Seinfeld it
was just such a bit amazing cast yeah
that she was sort of overshadowed a lot
I think yeah but then she you know then
you see or do these other things and you
go oh my god like so I miss it I'm not
overshadowing her and be like you feel
like I'm not overshadowing her up my
don't know Polly what do you think this
sure she overshadow yeah you might
probably overshadows yet another thing
about ya mclovin the one where yet the
orange mustache haha Roman shadow yeah
that overshadowed you that memo really
reverberate it over well I just could
not take my eyes off it she was she was
probably upset that you were getting
more attention that yeah she was maybe I
she certainly would yes so Matt Walsh is
uh let's see so you're in the do-over
you get well I can't say can I say that
you died in the movie I'll talk to I
don't know yeah the people from adam
sandler's moving you could die I don't
know if I die or not don't know that
yeah you could die I get that movie when
Sandler gets a hold of you and says all
right here's the script what you do I
actually I think I saw Sandler at dinner
at a restaurant the night before and I
got a call the next day because I
started Oh Adam but I also knew Steve
Brill and they're like hey there's this
part I'm like sure I'll do it and it was
in Atlanta so I didn't see the whole
script I just saw the scenes and he had
an accent I did a great accent I did it
great gone with the wind acts oh is that
what that was you got a Clark Clark
Gable type uh yeah or Hattie the maid I
don't know nothin about birthin no
babies that's right when that's right
way give me it can you call up that oh
well uh oh well I'm so sorry he's so
sorry it's all gone Oh Willa you can see
him in Ted the hangover due date old
school the do-over Sandler's movie and
ghostbusters so you're with all the
women and ghostbusters I am yeah I i
work with Homeland Security in that film
that's my role and we sort of harassed
the ladies can you stay another
signature I want to talk to you about
Chicago Chicago so if that Chili's
alright so we'll continue with the mat
die-hard Bears fan yes White Sox fan I'm
iffy on baseball but yes okay yeah the
Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
you